the head of uber is responding to a
scathing report about the ride-hailing
companies passenger safety protocols The
Washington Post reported Wednesday that
agents in ubers Special Investigations
Unit are coached to put the company's
reputation ahead of passenger safety
Kris Van Cleave spoke with uber CEO and
joins us now Chris what did he have to
say
well good morning he believes that that
article is based on hearsay uber says
that it used old facts and that the
company's policies and procedures have
evolved particularly in the last few
years now we spoke with Derek his raashi
shortly after uber formally unveiled a
number of new safety measures we first
reported here on CBS this morning an
optional verification system will
require drivers to get a pin code from
their riders before a trip can start
among the other features uber introduced
an in-app function allowing riders to
text 911 emergency the company hopes the
new features will help prevent the type
of mistake police believe Samantha
Josephson made when she appeared to
mistake a car for her uber in March she
was later found murdered now about the
post article uber CEO says if a victim
of sexual assault wants to report the
attack to police uber makes it quote
very easy to do so so we have done
everything that we can we've been
advised by law enforcement we have been
advised by victim advocacy group
advocacy groups to make sure that when
something does happen we respond in a
way that's victim centric that's victim
first what do you say to to these
reports and to folks who have have
either sued you or have suffered a
sexual assault that feel like the
response wasn't there I say that that
report fundamentally was based on
hearsay we're not perfect
I wouldn't claim to be perfect but I
believe that we're significantly better
than we were last year and next year
darn it we're going to be better
uber executives insist if they get a
report about an alleged sexual assault
against a driver that driver is
immediately removed from the system
there is no three strikes policy at uber
they say now Senator Richard Blumenthal
has sent letters to rideshare executives
Express
concern saying the industry needs to do
more Gail
all right Chris thank you very much